do you see a possible currency collapse
and potentially on what kind of time
scale no I don't think it's possible
it's going to be it's going to happen
inevitable so it will it because they
can't keep uh keep doing this but uh you
know you mentioned that uh you know some
of those people that took my advice I
wonder if they're going to give me a cut
no it just happened that uh it was an
alternative and so far the alternative
has made a lot of people rich but do you
think there were 10 people 100 people 5
000 people or or a million people that
bought that bought cryptocurrency or
crypto between 30 and 68.
and it's on the way up and then on the
way down there's a lot of buying as hell
and so so it is this some people make a
log but but the whole thing is is I want
a definition I mean you could they can
do it it would be legal as long as
there's no fraud involved